going to begin this hour with the search
for answers about kovid with the number
of new cases in this country averaging
more than 100 000 a day there's also
some possible good news we'll get to
moderna has announced results suggesting
a modified version of its covet vaccine
is more effective than the one currently
available and the company hopes to
submit that data to regulators in the
weeks ahead you might say there is no
one better to talk about all of this
than dr ashish shah the white house
covet 19 response coordinator and we're
happy to say he is here in studio dr
john good morning good morning thank you
now we have a sort of surprise for our
viewers that is gail king is going to be
joining us remotely right scott covid to
ask you a couple questions but before we
get to that just give us a reality check
of where we are with covid is what we're
living through right now kind of the
best we're going to be at
yeah so what we're seeing is you know
rise of infections across the country as
you said about a hundred thousand but
this rise feels different i think than
it often has and that's because we're
not seeing a lot of people land in the
hospital we're not seeing people in the
icu thankfully deaths are really low
compared to traditional and the question
is why what's going on what's different
one is we've got lots of people
vaccinated and boosted i think that's
making a big difference and then we've
done a lot of work to try to get packs
of it out there this is this oral pill
that makes a big difference keeping
people out of the hospital so i do think
that that is what's really keeping
serious illness low that's a big goal
right now is we got to make sure people
stay for sure dr jaw as tony mentioned
gail she tested positive so i think four
times you wanted to be real short right
right
so kovit has hit the cbs mornings um so
we want to bring her in uh gail i know
you're at home joining us right now
first let me ask how are you feeling
i i feel really fine but just hearing
you guys say gayle king has coveted got
me like this i still
doctors i still can't believe i'm
sitting here at home and you're there i
am double boosted i'm double backs i can
honestly say i feel okay
if i didn't know i had covet i wouldn't
know it was coped i thought it was a
slight cold
on saturday because i tested
negative friday slight cold saturday
positive monday and i still can't
believe i'm sitting here talking to you
this way because i've been so freaking
careful
yeah i know gail and look this is a very
very contagious virus
people are going to get it it's going to
be hard for people to stay away from it
but the good news i see you as a success
story hard to tell you that when you
have kovid but it is a success story
right like you are you've gotten
vaccinated you've gotten boosted and
that means you're not gonna get
particularly sick from this and thank
goodness
i actually do feel i have to say very
grateful that i'm double vaxxed and
double boosted so i'm not complaining
about that i actually feel very grateful
i'm now worried about long-term covet
i'm i'm trying to decide should i get
pax loved should i get monoclonal should
i do nothing because i honestly feel
okay i know i have to travel next week
out of the country and that's why i'm
considering it
yeah so look i mean in terms of whether
to get paxolvate or the monoclonal
antibodies good conversation to have
with your physician right
in general i believe that more and more
people should be getting this oral
antiviral pill pax love it i think it
makes a really big difference in keeping
people from getting particularly sick uh
so that's a good conversation to have
with your doctor gail but um in terms of
long covet i think thankfully people who
are vaccinated boosted much less likely
to get long coven
my hope is that you're going to do just
fine with this
well i can also say kobe doesn't take
away your appetite i was sorry to hear
that really i've been sitting at the
table picking at my navel because i've
been so paralyzed for the last couple
days trying to process today i'm
actually going to get up and move around
the house i'm going to do something
because i've been so paralyzed waiting
for something bad to happen and honestly
nothing bad has happened to me so i
really do need to
slap myself around and start moving and
accept this accept this diagnosis i know
i'll be okay and i'm hoping that i'll be
back at work very soon
yeah we are too gail yeah i understand
where she's coming from i mean i i've
avoided having it so far and i'm
thinking
for gayle's at home gail's testing we're
still testing at what point do we get to
in this country where we do treat it
like the flu because as you're saying
people the hospitalizations are down
people are not dying are we at that
point right yeah when do we get there if
we're not now and you just say if you
don't feel well you don't feel you don't
know if it's the flu or covet or what it
is yeah here's why i think we're not
quite there yet first of all the number
of infections that are out there we
don't ever have the flu where like
we get hundreds of thousands of people
getting infected every day this is a lot
of infections so we still got to work on
that second we are taking a very active
aggressive approach to keeping
hospitalizations down if we let up on
vaccinations if we let up on treatments
those hospitals can start climbing back
up again so we so it's sort of like
we're in a battle we're fighting hard
and keeping things at bay
it's not time to let up and say okay
this is as good as it gets i actually
think we can do much better than this
too if we develop new generation of
vaccines and keep going away we'll go in
after this virus
yeah i totally agree with what you're
saying i have a friend who was also got
it the same day i did his symptoms are
much worse than mine but i also know if
he wasn't double back vaxxed and boosted
he would be in a world of trouble so i
can't stress that enough how important
this is to be in this position that you
are well covered if it should hit you
and on another note guys this show is
very fun to watch i'm saying
god i wish i was there ariana's there
today yesterday you had grant hill
and layla the new brotherhood opened the
club it was so fun to watch you guys she
was well we're glad that you're watching
dr sheesh we appreciate you and gayle
king we're glad that you're feeling well
get up get out and do something all
right we miss you at the table and we
can't wait till you're back in